hold on buddy near shoka to ultra David
and James Chan to commentate this match
hi guys
alright we are going to see our first
ever live Street Fighter 5 match and
trust us we have no idea what's gonna
happen in this game look we we tried to
finagle our way into like playing the
game oh yeah I didn't work yeah it did
not work we try we try but no dice so
let us play let's just so we can
commentate a theater right exactly why
not it didn't work so we're basically
gonna be in the dark I don't know what's
gonna happen but in the meantime up
about five hundred thousand dollars -
that's ridiculous
oh my god next year crosscut is gonna be
insane amazing Capcom Pro Tour is gonna
continue amazing that is exciting stuff
shoutouts to everyone involved in that I
mean this is big stuff this is big stuff
fun fighting game community it's it's
2015 is going to be even bigger even
bigger alright
and I guess for to demo this game for
you guys we're gonna Sam
combo feed and Mike Ross now look I
talked to them a little bit earlier
today they said that there is not going
to be any love lost in this match oh
good they want a body each other in this
do you want to be the first person to
win the first live match of Street
Fighter 5 ever in the history just so
it'll be like trivia questions forever
you know personally I'm not gonna let
whoever loses live it down that's me I'm
just gonna make sure that happens
alright alright so were you are we
business real we plan right now oh okay
I got it
let's go alright ryu chun-li I guess my
meters three bars like only two for real
okay wow that's a crazy-looking medium
kick baby down strong I imagine look how
much meter you already built
look at that interesting back asset
chun-li hasn't canceled out of a back
asset look like so there's a revenge
hater right up at the prop counter hits
are any Ojo after lightning kicking no
no dice for that flip kick guessing the
uppercut in there yeah ex is ready to go
Cooper maybe
to stand away staying away maybe trying
to work on a super Johnny but look they
check out their revenge bars at the top
one okay you Tom the leader he pops the
reader his hands are electric now yes
but they're not electric anymore where
did that come from kinda fine like the
bar that although that used up that yeah
oh you're right okay yeah you're right
oh yeah rah
that was the revenge he use the revenge
meter you're right and the super and
just knocks Chumlee right through the
wall that okay so slow look it starts
right away and you can actually I you
gonna check claim between that's not
like a new edge oil activating okay okay
she gets double fireballs now wow wow
it's gone are you serious oh here we go
punish the Oh miss the throw come on
Mambo nice set knock down there Mike now
with that pole ax bar again
with any medal Nagas look like a quick
ride there oh there it is that's a good
girl
now I was damaging honest I mean do they
start right here it seems like to me
right now that something is hot okay
Chun Li is not a charged character yeah
it doesn't look like that huh guys just
walking oh here we go oh room oh there
and there okay we saw that work in the
trail Oh charges out for vengeance it
kid Oh whimper recently went back fine
along ethics just hanging out there
interesting cuz the bars down at the
bottom are canned chunks but I haven't
seen them use anything that only takes
one bar yeah that's true it's always the
whole thing oh here we go
Big Daddy maybe try the link didn't get
it you she's so not gonna happen
okay he just using the exit oh okay yeah
there was right what are you doing we
trying to chip
[Music]
to hit wait did that not chipper to
death oh maybe I saw lo Ford fireball
block I mean I feel like you're right
did you read about that and so Mike the
first game that's not a match needs to
be working on oh yeah Baxter
Mike lost I mean Mike Mike one that's a
common foe yo yo yo Peter wants to run
back he wants to roll back he wants to
run back mike is like no I won but Peter
wants to run back yeah Mike wants to
close it out skate away live okay oh man
Peter's like no you can't get away with
that one I want my revenge here we go
another match cold oh nice you sis a new
movie again one of the things I gotta
say a rim light box all the all the hits
and a good reeling that the characters
do match the attacks very well
really different
oh here's your juggling message I can
put okama fee means business now hit the
bro he's turned on my can getting ripped
up cavity lost the first round the first
time yeah maybe not boy oh yeah fair
enough
girls night
looks like to certain specific punches
always good okay quick damage here for
cobble beam oh look I can turn the link
after that didn't quite get it okay time
to go oh here we go water versus
lightning sooner bracelets are still
glowing blue Oh big jump in oh also
Cooper so who remains Lutheran event so
you can just combo into her event
oh dang just delicious hahaha
are you fear she still has the noodles
on her head oh and there oh no it's
still there she's got a permanent hat
now oh that was kind of safe but I guess
you need in
[Music]
copypasta now still sitting on her head
ODB you stop watching this bowl
oh wow that's you wake up interesting
like just might like just wants oh why
don't you do that
oh you're either the super Mike she's
had it come on Mike
oh that's it I'm gonna have to leave it
at 1 1 folks 1 1 they're tired at watch
you look at that pasta that's a pasta
that's really sticky I show up on all
around was told it was one game so I
felt like I won you know I'm saying like
I there's a fair assessment
I mean I was I was going really light on
you cuz I had a little bit more time
with
[Applause]
I'm just saying I'm just saying right
now guys it's to be continued it's one
one right now hey well thank you guys so
much for coming out to capcom cup that's
our show for this year we hope to see
all you guys here again next year in
2015 thank you so much thank you guys
all the players thank you capcom
everybody had a lot of fun we'll see you
guys next time
[Applause]